in the Gloom Helena prepares the
Christmas meal Russian attacks on the
energy grid have left many here reliant
on the intermittent power of a generator
the celebratory dinner is low-key her
husband and son are fighting on the
front lines
Tick-Tock videos are one way to stay in
touch but at this time of year their
absence is painful
um
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
does manage to get through on the phone
the network is patchy but a couple of
minutes is enough to connect and lift
the festive moods
foreign
[Music]
of nearly a year of war is felt most
strongly on the day of Orthodox
Christmas
but even in the churches you can hear
the unity and defiance
in this Cathedral the service is for the
first time conducted by the Ukrainian
Orthodox clergy the Russian Orthodox
Church an outcast amongst the
congregation reflecting another break
with Moscow
but as they watched outside worshipers
reflected on what they've lost in this
year of violence is
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
this has been an unbelievably difficult
and shocking year for Ukraine Vladimir
Putin's war of aggression has broken
families and caused immense pain
in Moscow the Russian leader looked
uncomfortable as he posed for State
television at a service inside the
Kremlin isolated and heavily sanctioned
the war he started shows no sign of
ending and the festive ceasefire he
commanded has been dismissed as
propaganda
but in Ukraine there is hope
as the snow falls gently people here are
praying for a swift Victory and the
return of their occupied lands
Alex Rossi Sky News Kiev